thumb up Mr Speaker the only mandate
she's ever had is from Members opposite
yeah
built on fantasy economics and it ended
in disaster the country's got nothing to
show for it except the destruction of
the economy and the implosion of the
Tory party I've got the list here 45p
tax cut gone corporation tax cut gone
20p tax cut gone two-year energy freeze
gone tax-free shopping gone economic
credibility gone
and her supposed best friend the formula
Chancellor he's gone as well they're all
gone so why is she still here
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I am a fighter and not a
quitter
I have acted in the National interest to
make sure that we have economic
stability order
order I'm going to hear the Prime
Minister I suggest that all members need
to hear the answer prime minister
[Applause]
I am a fighter
we have delivered on the energy price
guarantee we have we delivered on the
energy price guarantee we've delivered
on National Insurance we are going to
deliver to stop the militant trade
unions disrupting our Railways The
Honorable gentleman has no idea he has
no plan and he has no alternative